un respiro para los venezolanos en eeuu
el gobierno de yubá idem anunció que 320
mil venezolanos podrán acogerse al
estatus de protección temporal que les
permitirá trabajar y residir legalmente
en el país hay una compleja situación
humanitaria con hambre extendida
malnutrición y la creciente presencia de
grupos armados no estatales e
infraestructuras en ruinas la medida
tendrá una vigencia de 18 meses
prorrogables y la podrán solicitar los
que estén en eeuu desde antes del lunes
8 de marzo desde su publicación este
martes los venezolanos tendrán 180 días
para acogerse al programa tendrán que
demostrar no tener antecedentes penales
y tendrán que pagar tasas de unos 535
dólares los venezolanos que residen en
eeuu celebraron la medida
y hay mucha gente que no tiene la plata
para pedirlas y luego van llegando y no
saben qué hacer mintiendo y la medida
pone de acuerdo a republicanos y
demócratas desde venezuela el opositor
juan guaidó agradeció a eeuu raciones 1
mientras que el canciller jorge arreaza
instó a la casablanca a retirar las
sanciones señor secretario blinken en
aras de la coherencia lo que debería
exigirse es que así como la onu ha
exigido su administración levante
inmediatamente las crueles sanciones que
han generado todo tipo de dificultades y
dolor a la gente así como serias
restricciones e impactos en la economía
venezolana el estatus de protección
temporal es un programa migratorio
creado en 1990 que tiene por objetivo
conceder permisos a inmigrantes de
naciones a las que no es seguro volver
según la onu venezuela vive una de las
peores crisis humanitarias del mundo y
alrededor de 54 millones de venezolanos
han dejado el país en los últimos años